da
quoi
peau d'iron l'un des nouveaux
personnages de l'opus star wars 7 est un
pilote de chasseur servant auparavant la
nouvelle république puis maintenant la
résistance contre le premier ordre
c'est l'un des premiers personnages que
nous apercevons au début du film et
c'est là que nous nous rendons compte
que ce personnage sur un important il
est le propriétaire du droid bébé 8 qui
jouera un rôle clé dans l'histoire
meilleurs pilotes de la résistance peau
est un personnage qui se démarque très
facilement des autres par son attitude
son charisme et ses talents de pilote
mais connaissons-nous réellement peau
d'iron cette vidéo sera la dernière
vidéo théorique sur star wars 7 car je
pense sincèrement que nous avons fait le
tour et j'aimerais parler d'autres
sujets qui m'intéressent tout autant
mais en attendant voyons les trois
théories que je vous propose
je conçois que cette théorie plutôt
facile mais je tenais à vous la partagez
et en penser par moi même wild and this
est un très grand pilote de chasseur qui
servit l'alliance rebelle puis la
nouvelle république
il est le meilleur pilote de son époque
il combattit aux côtés de luke skywalker
et fut l'un des uniques survivants de
l'assaut contre l'étoile noire qui fut
détruite par la suite par ses actions
pour l'alliance rebelle contre les
forces du mal
il commandera par la suite l'escadron
raid en compagnie du général laudau
calrissian pour s'introduire et défaire
l'étoile de la mort
cette mission fut un réel succès et
l'étoile de la mort fut détruite ainsi
que l'empereur par l'intervention de luc
où je veux en venir c'est que wade est
le plus grand pilote de son époque
servant l'alliance rebelle et est
toujours vivant à la fin de la saga
il a mené à bien plusieurs missions
capital et on retrouve les mêmes
caractéristiques chez peau prenons pour
exemple les skywalker de père en fils et
peut-être filles en plus ont toujours eu
des dons pour la mécanique le pilotage
où la force
cela pourrait être la même chose pour
wade et pau de plus ils ont tous deux
servi la nouvelle république où elle
j'aurais très bien pu concevoir un
enfant dans cet havre de paix étant
donné que le mal et des faits il aurait
orienté son fils à devenir pilote pour
la nouvelle république
car très souvent le père veut que son
fils soit comme lui et même le pilotage
passionne peau il est vrai que cette
théorie est simple et pas très recherché
mais il est tout à fait possible et
serait une référence aux anciennes
versions
mais il est fort possible que pau soit
seulement un nouveau personnage créé
pour cette saga
cette théorie est vraiment la plus
intéressante détroit je vous laisse en
juger par vous même
mais cette fois ci je laisserais mon ami
picsou elle de la chaîne pour faire
simple vous la présenter merci argot
rock et bonjour à tous sa recette à des
normes ressemblance avec star wars 4
c'est presque un calque nous en avons la
preuve dans plusieurs éléments mais un
seul nous intéresse pour cette théorie
c'est le triangle amoureux comme dans
star wars
4 nous pouvons remarquer un triangle
autour de trois personnages soif fine
ray et pau auparavant c'était bien
évidemment les ya'an et luc ce que nous
pouvons remarquer c'est que ces deux
triangles sont composés de deux garçons
et de deux filles dans les anciennes
versions les gars étaient au sommet de
ce triangle luc fut sous le charme de
cette dernière
puis il s'est avéré que c'était sa soeur
donc le terrain était libre pour le
contrebandier en solo qui était très
attiré par les ja cependant la tournure
pourrait être vu autrement
les temps ont changé ont évolué
l'homosexualité n'est plus aussi tabou
quelle époque
a contrario de la femme au sommet du
triangle ce serais fine qui serait
convoité par à la fois ray et pau
comment pouvons-nous leurs remarques et
le lien entre peau est fine
dès le moment où fine sauf qu on ressent
un lien très proche entre les deux
personnages ils s'entendraient et se
donne même un petit surnom
enfin seulement pour fine puis prenons
l'exemple de l'arrivée de fines au qg de
la résistance nous avons le droit à pau
qui saute dans les bras de fines ce cas
là est le plus passionné
si je puis dire et le plus émotionnel on
sent une grande amitié entre les deux
hommes ou peut-être autre chose
puis pour lui laisse même sa veste en
lui affirmant qu'elle lui va mieux
j'en conviens que cette théorie n'est
pas totalement fondée et est facilement
contestée mais quand on regarde tous ces
petits détails entre chaque dialogue ou
même entrepôt et fine on pourrait
facilement penser que quelque chose se
passe entre les deux hommes n'hésitez
pas à nous dire ce que vous en pensez
je rends la place arago
merci pixels au plaisir je tenais à vous
faire part de cette théorie pour son
originalité mais bon pause serait
contrôlé par cas et lorraine après que
finn et pau se soit écrasé sur jack ou
pau aurait été enlevée par le premier
ordre et ce serait pour ça que finn le
croyait mort suite à ça qu'elle lorraine
aurait de nouveau utiliser ses pouvoirs
sur lui mais cette fois ci dans
l'intention d'en faire un espion du
premier ordre puis l'aurait renvoyé dans
la résistance
cette théorie aurait pu être
intéressante mais le problème c'est que
pau détruit la base darkiller cependant
caille lorraine et le suprême leaders ne
sont pas très affecté par la destruction
de celles ci donc aurait-il fait exprès
de laisser là bas starkiller être
détruite pour réellement infiltrés peau
mystère mais personnellement je ne pense
pas et cette théorie ne tient pas
réellement debout pourquoi pas aurait-il
été ramené sur le vaisseau du premier
ordre
suite au crash et n'aurait pas ramené
fine qui après se fait poursuivre par
ceux ci ou bien pourquoi pause semble
autant sain d'esprit et participe à la
destruction de la ba starkiller s'en
allait donner les planqués lorraine
cette théorie ne tient pas debout
mais je tenais à vous la faire partager
pour conclure n'hésitez pas à aller voir
la chaîne de mon ami pic soit elle qui
fait un excellent travail de vidéos
notamment avec l'ouverture de sa
nouvelle chaîne
pour faire simple qui consiste à
expliquer très simplement des questions
des sujets un peu complexe simplement je
vous laisse aller la découvrir merci
d'avoir regardé la vidéo que la force
soit avec ceux qui partagent on est
laïque rond la vidéo ça m'aide
énormément et me soutient c'était tard
goreux que le lionheart soit avec vous